استدعت وزاره الخارجيه الباكستانيه سفيرها
من ايران على خلفيه قصف طهران لاراضي
باكستانيه وحملت المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه
الباكستانيه ممتاز زهر بلوش حملت ايران
مسؤوليه عواقب ما قامت به مؤكده ان بلادها
تحتفظ بحق الرد الموقف الباكستاني ياتي
بعد يوم من اعلان وكاله انباء التسنيم
الايرانيه ان الجيش الايراني دمر مقرا
لتنظيم ما وصفه بجيش العدل الارهابي في
باكستان وبصو ومسيرات
اير ان الانتهاك غير المبرر الذي حدث
الليله الماضيه لسياده باكستان من قبل
ايران يعد انتهاكا للقانون الدولي وميثاق
الامم المتحده وهذا العمل غير القانوني
غير مقبول على الاطلاق وباكستان تحتفظ بحق
الرد على هذا العمل ومسؤوليه عواقبه ستقع
على عاتق ايران بشكل مباشر وقد ابلغ ايران
بقرارنا سحب سفيرنا من طهران وبان السفير
الايراني لدى باكستان والذي يزور ايران
حاليا لن يعود في الوقت الحالي وقد قررنا
كذلك تعليق جميع الزيارات واللقاءات
رافيعه المستوى التي كان مخططا لها وتلك
القائمه حاليا بين باكستان وايران وحتى
للايام المقبله